bonsoir régis merci d'être avec nous
j'irais là ça devant couverture du
newsweek ans et pas forcément pour ans
on en reparle washington dément toute
normalisation il n'empêche il semble
revenir au centre du jeu le président
syrien pour quelles raisons alors ils
sombrent revenir au centre du jeu ça
fait déjà un petit moment parler des
émirats des émirats aurait ouvert leur
ambassade il ya deux ans et donc il y a
eu plusieurs rappels la jordanie
évidemment a commencé à retraités avec
avec le gouvernement assad également le
liban aussi qui est en crise mais quand
même il ya eu des des parlementaires
libanais qui se sont rendus en syrie
c'était la première fois depuis dix ans
et progressivement en fait la raison
principale c'est que on sent bien que
beaucoup de pays arabes au fonctionne de
façon assez pragmatique et dans la crise
syrienne il y 6 e ils se rendent compte
qu'il ya un état de fait c'est la
victoire de bachar al assad c'est à dire
que on peut comment critiquer l'homme on
peut critiquer sa position peut
critiquer tout ce qu'il a fait la
réalité c'est que ya dix ans qu'elle est
quasiment perdu le contrôle des deux
tiers de son territoire et
qu'aujourd'hui il en est il arrivé
renard conquis environ 85 % il reste les
kurdes vous avez mentionné correspondant
aux états unis a mentionné la présence
des américains 900 américains mais en
réalité il reste la zone dite libre donc
au nord-ouest qui compte toujours
contrôlé par l'opposition est-ce qu'il
est principalement par le groupe j ai
dit ça ya taille al cham et que en
dehors de ça il a reconquis le pays donc
il ya une sorte de d'état de fait qui
fait que beaucoup de pays arabes se
disent vu la position centrale de
l'aciérie au moyen-orient on le voit
très bien d'un point de vue économique
également puisque il ya un plan
justement d'acheminer vers le liban des
hydrocarbures égyptien et de
l'électricité jordanienne et ce plan-là
prévoit que ça passe par la syrie c'est
un plan qui a eu l'approbation tacite
des états unis alors aujourd'hui il ya
une sorte d'emballement mais à partir du
moment où la diplomatie américaine dit
nous ne traitons pas avec bachar al
assad nous n'allons pas vers une
normalisation de nos relations avec la
syrie ça veut dire quand même qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe et puis
l'autre tas de fait c'est qu'on a on a
oublié enfin on l'a pas oublié mais le
fait que les américains aujourd'hui
traite avec les talibans on se dit
pourquoi neutre être est il pas
également ou en tout cas nous nous
rétablir est il pas des relations avec
le gouvernement assad lac et la question
elle est aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire du moyen-orient qu'est-ce que
comment on veut que cette zone
finalement
rivère vers une normalisation en tout
cas une pacification justement régit
cette victoire des talibans le fait
qu'on traite avec eux ça veut dire que
maintenant les amis américains parlent
avec des gens qu'ils estimé auparavant
infréquentable c'est cette étape on
vient de franchir justement je pense que
dans le mouvement qui est en train de de
caumont de provoquer vu qu'ils sont en
train de provoquer des etats-unis dans
le monde engrais réajustant leurs
politiques internationales il ya un
constat de réalisme il ya un constat
d'intérêt américains on l'a vu avec la
faire des sous marins on l'a vu avec eux
un certain nombre avec le retrait des
troupes américaines d'afghanistan c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui les américains ont
des priorités et que les priorités
évidemment ce ne sont plus le moyen
orient ni rési centrale c'est la chine
et donc il ya une rue un halo une amorce
d'une
d'un changement majeur dans la politique
étrangère américaine et face à ça
évidemment les états unis ont finalement
provoqué le retour des talibans au
pouvoir faut rappeler quand même que les
talibans en termes de crime c'est
l'objet disque plus criminels des dix
dernières années donc
donc c'est on discute avec des gens
aujourd'hui à doha qui ont qui ont passé
leur vie dans la clandestinité qui ont
perpétré des attentats j'ai pas cité les
noms blémant du gouvernement mais un
certain nombre qui sont impliqués dans
des actes comment pour lesquelles les
américains les avait d'une certaine
façon désignée comme terroriste
aujourd'hui donc les américains des ide
dialogue avec des gens qui considéré
autrefois comme des terroristes donc ce
réalisme ces prises en compte aussi de
l'émergence d'autres d'autres puissances
le vide près créée par les américains
par leur retrait en partiel d'irak et
total d'afghanistan et bien fait que des
puissances local régional
émergent je pense en particulier à la
turquie mais également
à l'iran qui revient aussi dans l'est
dans le jeu des négociations et tout ça
c'est que la politique américaine
aujourd'hui elle est beaucoup plus
pragmatique et donc
sur la vie sur le volet syrien il ya
aussi une interrogation comment voilà on
ne peut pas traiter les problèmes du
dimanche si on est très pas les
problèmes de la syrie et est aujourd'hui
il y a plus d'acteurs donc les états
unis prend prennent d'une certaine façon
comment conscience qu' il y à d'autres
acteurs et que eux ne sont plus dans le
jeu ça veut dire en gros leur ton du
réalisme après des décennies de
messianisme démocratique s'est terminée
ça alors tout à fait on sait que mais
c'est terminé c'est pas terminé avec le
gouvernement bailon salle était déjà
avec le gouvernement tron je rappelle
que trump malgré tout sa rhétorique
enflammée n'a jamais déclenché une
guerre c'est un des rares présidents
américains ne pas l'avoir fait barack
obama lui avant était déjà sur cette
ligne ne faut jamais oublier que barack
obama est un président président
américain qui a été élu sur une ligne
anti-guerre par rapport à son
prédécesseur george bush et donc que ce
mouvement il a commencé d'ailleurs le
mouvement de retrait d'afghanistan et de
retrait d'irak 1 on l'a oublié mais 2017
sous barack obama que les troupes
américaines sont revenus un peu de façon
un peu précipité puisque du coup des ch
a émergé juste après mais on peut dire
ce mouvement américain se replie
américains vers ses propres intérêts que
donald trump à a synthétisé dans la
formule america first et bien il a déjà
été
commencées dans les législatures
précédentes donc maintenant on en voit
aussi beaucoup de conséquences on est
arrivé au terme de l'engagement
américain en afghanistan avec la
conséquence qui est le retour des
taliban maintenant il est probable
également que les américains ne
resteront pas des années en syrie et en
irak pour la bonne et simple raison
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus grand
chose à y faire merci beaucoup régis le
sommier grand reporter tesfran simple
pour votre analyse ce soir merci